now allow me to show you something
completely different because the
democrats had a chance
they really did have a chance in that
last election because there was one sane
human being
on that uh that podium when they were
having their debates and they destroyed
her not only did they destroy her
uh you know who i'm talking about
already tulsi gabbard obviously but
hillary clinton claimed that she was
working for the russians mitt romney in
the last month or so claim that she's
working for the russians and she's a
traitor this is tulsi gabbard who was
congresswoman from hawaii democrat
congresswoman from hawaii who is an
active member of our military which has
been in training over the last couple
weeks
they they completely destroyed her
i don't know where someone that is
roughly sane fits in the modern
democratic party but tulsi who's now out
of politics and i don't know exactly
what her future holds i don't know if
she wants to get into politics
or not uh she's still talking the truth
and she's still holding the same line
which is very difficult as someone that
i think still believes that they're on
the left again i don't want to speak for
tulsi uh here's a video she put up on
instagram over the weekend talking about
hb1557 otherwise known as the don't say
gay or straight bill
you may have seen in the news recently
or you may be a parent who's experienced
how parental rights are under attack all
across the country as the government
tries to usurp parents rights and
responsibility to raise their own
children
now we should all support the parental
rights and education bill that recently
passed in florida which very simply bans
government and government schools from
indoctrinating woke sexual values in our
schools
to a captive audience a captive audience
that is by law required to attend
but as i read the legislation i got to
tell you i was shocked to learn that it
only protects kids from kindergarten
till third grade
third grade what about 12th grade
or not at all
now government
has no place in our personal lives
government has no place in our bedrooms
parents are the ones responsible for
raising their kids and instilling in
them a moral foundation not the
government
who seems more sane
is it jen saki
is it nancy pelosi
is it joe biden
is it kamala harris
or is it the lady that the entire party
and the entire machine tried to destroy
what's extraordinary about that video
actually well first off she's calm and
clear and decent like you can feel it
right you can always feel it with her
but what's really extraordinary about
that video is that what she's saying is
in essence desantis didn't go far enough
that it shouldn't just be k through
three that
up until 12th grade
you should not be teaching this stuff in
schools that's a really interesting
position to have now we can have some
discussion i think of what a health
class should teach
uh related to
the body and puberty and all of the
things that kids are going through and i
had health class in seventh grade but
they weren't pushing gender identity
stuff on us they weren't telling you
that you should uh transition from one
gender to another and then try to hide
that from the parents so tulsi just i
mean i i believe that was an intentional
line and that that's a pretty powerful
line that she's saying he did not even
go far enough
so what's the theme now that we've come
to the almost the ending of today's show
although i want you to stick around for
the uh the cold clothes today it's a
good one
um what's the theme here well if you
start with elon musk you got a guy who
most people think of as really just a
technologist and innovator not
particularly political somewhat
libertarian in some ways but then you
know enjoys his government subsidies but
he will now be thought of as a right
winger sort of because he's trying to
clean up things related to speech and we
know that it's the conservative side or
the right that's having their speech
stifled okay
then we jump all the way to tulsi and
you have a democrat congresswoman former
congresswoman who is now
in some ways related to this hb-1557
sounding more right wing that's not
really the case but more let's say
conservative
than even ron desantis who's being
called a nazi and everything else by
mainstream media this all shows you how
insane the left has gone and and
even bigger than that i think what it
shows you
is what i'm actually really interested
in right now which is what will this
alliance look like how will we have an
alliance of technologists like elon musk
how will we have an alliance of say
more traditionally religious people say
like my evangelical christian friends
and an orthodox jew like ben shapiro how
do we couple that with someone a refugee
i know a little bit about the refugees
from the left a refugee of the left like
tulsi gabbard
all of us having wildly different
personal religious beliefs philosophies
all of those things but all going man
america is pretty good
individual rights are pretty good we
want to build new things while they burn
everything down that's a great story
that's what i'm interested in uh that's
how i ended the show on friday that that
that piece of now okay we've seen it
we've seen the thing the curtains back
we've seen it you guys aren't going to
stop i get it department of education is
never going to stop california is never
going to stop
what do we have to do to disconnect from
these people and how can we find all of
the people that can fit into our wide
tent which is exactly what america is
all about that's what i'm interested in
i think that's what you're interested in
and that's what i'm going to keep
furthering